hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to factorial with Bob
hello Bob what's up everybody
what's up okay so we got a plan for the
next one and the plan involves testing
our intelligence because it's been a
while since we've been in college Bob
but I imagine that we can still figure
this [ __ ] out so I I've reached about
the level of where I have played on my
own and now we're in the experimental
phase where we're trying to figure out
the best way to automate literally
everything mm-hmm do that we need more
science we need more labs we need more
intricate ways to make those automation
machines happen so Bob take it away
well I did just have an idea it's it's
not that smart but I'm about to place a
smart gravity goo behind this chest
that's full of coal but also copper ore
and recycle the copper ore into the into
the line that's smart that is very smart
it doesn't have much to do with the
giant automation of automatic science
that I was talking about but it's not
nuts it's cool though right so yeah I
just need so good to make it to make a
power pole cuz my power systems sucks
yeah I mean I wasn't gonna question but
you got like a criss-crossing web of
horror yeah mine's all nice and unique
but that's fine
that's beautiful I love it right it's
not it's not grabbing out of the chest I
uh it should be okay it's supposed to
grab out of the chest oh there's no
copper in there oh I just took it out
yeah I'm staying on I put the SD there
there Oh Rama genius food and automation
to finish which means that we can make
the bigger assembly machines and the
bigger assembly she machines means that
we can make automatically make products
that take three items so now we can
automate science to because it needs to
make the in Surtur's I always should do
that yes we should be fun okay so this
requires an even bigger
with even more automation facilities and
a whole bunch of crap so I can only
imagine yes I could we're we're we're
we're gonna build this to the right over
there and that clearing yeah our
original science Factory now to actually
make a lot of sense because if we do it
over here then we could just keep
clearing out the woods here and then
keep it a little bit away from the lake
that way we can keep the steam engines
going to the lake but soon we'll be able
to make solar power which means solar
power sounds awesome
yeah but the thing about solar power is
only available during the day and you
still have to rely on steam engines
until you get more stuff I mean
eventually I haven't gotten there yet
but you'll get oil processing and you'll
be able to do that stuff and and just
generally be able to that sounds really
complicated so I'm just gonna build two
of these new assembling machines okay
cuz cuz I can and I assume we need them
probably it takes some amount of time
yep either like a day or like five
minutes sir yeah something like that I
mean I've got okay I've got let's see
I've got I'd only have one I should have
five assembly machines oh they're on the
way they're still being made okay so all
right thinking about this using my big
brain so to make science the green
science the science back to you need an
inserter and a transport belt so you
need an assembly machine that's making
the transport belts which makes
transport belts just take iron plates
and gear wheels so you need a machine
making gear wheels in the same loop that
it's making the transporter belts you
need inserters because and inserters are
the ones that take three ingredients so
you need another machine that's making
electronic circuits and to make an
electronic circuit you need another
machine that's making copper cable at a
copper plate so the only way yeah I know
the only inputs are iron and copper but
the assembly machines inside are also
making copper cable iron gears and was
there anything else electronic circuits
so copper cable electronic circuits iron
gear here I got the start for you ready
I'm ready nailed it thank you Bob hey
now that I just want to say I
contributed you are you are welcome sir
thank you Bob
you are so smart let our brilliant
second you know what I I can't deny this
is what this might be the most important
thing that you've ever built here I you
might say I came up with the entire idea
yeah I would say you did that and also I
realized we can't build here because if
freaking stone is in the way like Oh
dick so well yeah okay so we can do this
up we can do it to the south here yeah I
didn't mean to totally destroy your
incredible always place but it's okay
I'll just oh it's okay are you sure
you're okay because I don't I don't want
to I don't want to make you mad you know
oh uh uh how does [ __ ] do I destroy the
stone rock oh you can just write with
your gun it just takes a lot of
don't-don't-don't damage don't don't
don't don't do it it's working I'm
almost out of ammo though don't worry
yeah we had an automation facility that
there we go it just it disadvantaged all
right I got lots of em oh well too late
doc sorry buddy gone you got lots of
ammo let me alone okay I commend you on
your ammo I'm actually shocked that we
haven't been attacked yet because they
at home haven't seen the aliens and the
unbelievable pain and suffering that was
brought upon us and the lat and the
pre-recording stuff yeah the extreme
Ducie tree of us dying horribly -
horrifying aliens okay so in the loop
you'll we only need one gear maker
because you know it makes gears super
fast so we only need one so let's just
place them down one at a time I'll place
one then you place one and then we'll
just go from there okay Oh steal all the
iron okay so one the v's that's four
gears so I'm going to make this four
gears okay alright so it only needs iron
so the next one because we need to make
an inserter and we need to make
transport belts we need okay so the
thing that makes transport belts only
needs gears in metals so
those are both gonna be coming in make
sense yes no no god damn it Bob all
right so I'm just trying to visualize in
my mind so we need one arm picking up
iron and putting it into this one yes
okay I can visualize that should it be
faster now it should just be regular
yeah regular electronic inserter
okay so I'll put an insert like this
like just for now and assume the belt
maybe we'll run over here and we'll see
what happens yeah okay that's good
assumption and this one's gonna be the
transport machine so this it'll grab
it'll grab from here or it'll grab on
the belt after this one's done and then
we'll go here and then so this one needs
an arm like say up here going into it
yes that is bad okay so that's going
there and then the next one is the
starting of making the inserter part so
we need one machine here making copper
cables so we need another right there
making copper cable all right
hope you're writing this down because
there will be a quiz talking to the
people out there so that was making
supper-table
okay and then the next one is going to
take the copper cable and mix it with
iron plate to make electronics so this
one's for electronics and then finally
at the end of the loop is one that is
making the inserter itself which takes
four parts so I think we can bring it
back around
so we're saying we're looping down and
then that goes there
so this is making the inserters so then
we have transport belt coming out of
this one all the ingredients for the
inserter coming out of this one and then
we can just put the machines that are
going to make the science and we can
overdo that so how many level one
assembly machines do you have four okay
put three right behind those other ones
okay just want to make level one science
no level two science this is a level
just want to make level hufa you were
all you were so close to being right
there Bob you were doing great but okay
oh all right so now we've got three of
these for level three signs so I'm gonna
make just a loop around it oops [ __ ]
kind of so they still need they still
need inserters in right yes so work on
making the inserters and I will MIT why
is the music so ominous did you hear
that no reason nothing horrible is about
to happen at all nothing why would you
question don't worry about it I I wasn't
worried okay I'm I'm gonna be really
impressed if this all pans out I just
want to say that yeah because also I'm
gonna try to make a splitter we're in
the part of this and I I don't even know
how splitters work but I built one so
let's give it a go and I've also got
underground belts okay splitter oh
you're making a splitter I was just
gonna make a smart grabber smart grabber
too but also split what is that is a
splitter what is that doing what the
hell what does it do can I make a smart
splitter oh god what would that do to it
I don't know what that do cheese oh so
what happens if you put one into it uh I
don't know just for sanity sake I'm
gonna oh I guess wait hang on we could
have made these okay actually I'm going
to redo these just to save some space so
going oh yeah yeah going out we could
have made them all like this yeah yeah
in in and out crap okay there we go
god damnit there we go okay so now we
can just bring the loop farther in and
that should be okay okay and then I have
no goddamn idea how this blur is gonna
work so we're gonna look at that after
we get this thing actually going okay so
now go get some iron and copper and then
we're gonna just be building the outside
parts in oh I got lots of iron and
copper don't you worry about it
I would I shouldn't I should learn never
be worried when you're around I got I
got all that I got all that in here yeah
okay so in theory this should work
stir I don't know I feel the need to
yell that but I'm just like in theory
this should absolutely hundred percent
without a doubt work oh you're doing
that already I just made a bunch of
power poles I'm too slow now I got you
covered
I were a team cooperative remember all
right that's got to be everything
powered up right now we just need inputs
hang on I got the inputs don't you worry
about it I wasn't worried why would I be
worried so the input should start right
here because this will put them right
into the beginning of the process right
yes like that
yes yeah oh [ __ ] except for I put it
outside the stupid it's okay I won't
criticize just yeah thank you for not
saying anything out loud I appreciate
that you're doing one that I need a
bunch of copper uh-huh and I'm a fired
yeah okay now they're facing the wrong
way I'll spin them around for you oh
yeah indeed so now it should be grab yes
okay your machine is going copper wire
machine is going copper wire just went
in yeah okay I like it okay all right
cool I need to put lights around here so
we can see this yeah I was just gonna
grab some resources oh you got wings
versus four lights I got whatever I was
thinking that same thing I was right
there thinking it with you it's okay we
understand and then the blue the blue
one is doing things yeah who had to
finish steel processing yeah okay so the
blue ones turning out in Surtur's or
it's thinking about it really it needs
iron plate still to come around okay
it's it's time to plate it's not made it
around yet [ __ ] damn thee the gear
is really greedy on the iron plate the
gearbox
they aren't okay yeah yeah I should make
a different iron supply for that side a
little bit yeah that might be a good
idea I'm thinking we probably need more
electronics production because this is a
lot of copper wire so one gear is more
than enough for everything but but we
might need is more electronics
production so I might extend this but
let's see how this goes first no not
there it's just gonna it's gonna feed
back to the gears no it's not it's gonna
go right in here
oh okay nevermind oh wait no the
electronics needs iron too oh well I
guess we could have just put the one by
the electronics and then let it so which
one is the electronics this one yeah
this top right top right is he liked so
I should put it like here yeah that
would be okay
any any day now I'll understand
completely what in the hell I'm supposed
to be hope I didn't put the iron in I
don't think any of us are expected to
know exactly what the hell we're doing
because we can read guides and [ __ ] yeah
that oh oh God does that sound like
something that we would do it sounds
like something we'd attempt to do and
then blame each other for failing okay
I'm gonna see what the splitter does it
did nothing I think you have to put it
in the path of something what we're
talking about like here here I am what
if we like this is gonna [ __ ] everything
up if I do this I'm down for it I think
we should make an experimental well
whatever I was gonna go like this uh-huh
and turn this so that it it what hey
there now put the splitter like on the
end of that and see what happens
oh ah mmm that's weird
now everything is ruined here but
everything is horrible god damn it I
just want to say you lose one science
though that I know this can produce one
science it can do
I feel like this is not possibly the
most efficient way that this setup could
be set up because it seems like I just
don't know how to space it out any
differently it's okay it's cool
this episode is just a lot of us making
thinking faces yeah it's ok because we
just got the electronic scene simple
atronics coming out yeah one of the
electronics was facing the wrong
direction so it's okay it's fine
come on okay the assembly is there's not
a lot of room on the outside that band
is going for it it's thinking about it
oh it's making sick MA to science it's
little remo about needs to put it down
yeah we made one we [ __ ] did it man
oh man
well now it's actually consuming a lot
more products yeah now the only one now
it's really cranking okay I think it
just needs some balancing like it needs
to have more of some less of others and
then bigger loop in general but I think
this is actually a good design Wow Eliot
there's another science coming out yes
science we ride the science to the end
yay
well it's not a good design but it
didn't open it it does things hey you
know what it makes science yeah yeah got
a chest with for level 2 science Hey
okay so that's good enough for this
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you Bob for helping me
figure the help that out because holy
hell that was that took that was amazing
after everyone in the comments is
marveling at our intelligence but hey
thank you Bob and thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always we will
see you in the next video bye-bye
way more see lambs to the slaughter
air hug bear grylls how many bear plugs
are we gonna fit in here can I get a
bear counter